this is a production of cornell
university
so
i am chris smart i am a plant
pathologist i study diseases of plants
mostly vegetables but we also have
several projects on hemp
uh my student patrick and i talked this
morning about root rot diseases in hemp
and this afternoon uh my student ally
calla who just completed her ph.d
[Laughter]
she got her phd studying hemp powdery
mildew and ali is going to tell us
a bit about her work
uh including on the host range of the
hemp powdery mildew and also about the
impact of um fungicides and
diseases on cannabinoid content in hemp
so ally cool
hi everybody
good afternoon
so like chris was saying my dissertation
research has focused mostly on
powdery mildew on hemp
powdery mildew on hemp is caused by a
fungal pathogen called
gulab gulabinomyces ambrosia
and
if you know anything about powdery
mildews there are lots and lots of
different species of powdery mildews
that affect different crops and they
tend to be very host specific which just
means that
a single powdery mildew tends to only
infect a single host or closely related
hosts
so
but we have actually found something
contradictory to that in hemp powdery
mildew we first identified hemp powdery
mildew here in new york state in 2019
and that's when i began working on this
project and
was looking through the literature just
to find out about
um
more about this pathogen and see what
was already out there and i actually
found
there wasn't a lot of literature but we
did find that
this particular species was being
reported on a variety of different crops
so that was interesting and a little bit
confusing because like i said powdery
mildews tend to have a very specific
host range so i started doing some
growth chamber experiments in 2020
just taking powdery mildew that we had
gotten from hemp samples in the field
and using that powdery mildew to
inoculate a variety of different crops
so we inoculated
sunflower
a few cucurbits and okra to begin with
and we found that the powdery was able
to infect
um
some of the good carpets particularly
cucurbite pepo
the sunflower
and the okra
so chris is walking around with
some
leaf samples of some of those crops that
we're seeing this powdery mildew on
we also
did a field trial last year where we
expanded
the species that we
the
host species that we were screening so
we screened
a variety of cucurbita people
varieties
uh some a few different
sunflower cultivars okra cultivars
and zinnia cultivars all of which were
susceptible to this pottery mildew
species
but one thing we did find in the field
was that all the cucurbita
pipo species varieties that we screened
while we saw that they were susceptible
in the growth chamber experiments we all
we saw in the field
they became very infected and when we
um
sequenced those samples to identify them
we found a different
powdery mildew species on the cucurbits
so the species we found was phosphorous
anthei and this is another
pottery mildew species that is the main
causal agent of cucurbit powdery mildew
so what we think is happening there is
that the cucurbits are susceptible to
this hemp powdery mildew but the
pedostera species is out competing in
the field when they're both
present
um
so this was just something to maybe keep
in mind when you're out planting
being mindful of
other crops that you're planting nearby
or maybe in a
controlled environment like something
like this or greenhouse just being
mindful of
the crop species that you're planting
nearby
if you're trying to control for powdery
mildew
so the other project that chris
mentioned was our fungicide
efficacy trials um i i've done two
years of trials now um
last year i presented some data on that
showing we found a few
products that are labeled for hemp in
new york that were effective
at reducing powdery mildew disease
severity
and
then we repeated that trial last year so
now we have two years of data to show
that
those products were effective
one of one of them is the cell matrix
which is the potassium silicate
and i believe is also part of this trial
so savannah we'll talk a bit about that
in a bit and then the other product we
found that was
successful in reducing powdery mildew
was a
double nickel which is a bacillus
species of biocontrol
product
we also tested in those trials whether
both the pathogen infection so powdery
mildew infection
and
fungicide
treatment would we tested to see whether
those would affect cannabinoid
production so we tested these on high on
a high cannabinoid
in high
high cannabidiol and high
cbg
cultivars and we tested all of the main
cannabinoids
at the end of the season and we found
that
neither pathogen infection or
the fungicide treatment
impacted
cannabinoid production in both ears and
both different cultivars
so yeah do you want to add anything
chris
yeah so i will also say that
powdery mildew here at cornell uh
sorry powdery mildew is the pathogen
that we are furthest along in breeding
for resistance
um
ally actually uh did a screen
and did all the rating of a screen of a
large number of
cultivars of hemp
and we have identified uh several
different genes that are responsible for
susceptibility or resistance to powdery
mildew and hemp and we're working with
the breeding program to get those
incorporated into
the hemp cultivars that they release and
so we're really excited one of the genes
that we identified is actually
a susceptibility gene
so when that protein is in the plant the
plant is susceptible to powdery mildew
but in the cultivar that we identified
that was resistant it was really
completely resistant and that gene had a
natural mutation in it the plant grew
fine
so far we haven't seen any impacts on
yield but that natural mutation was
preventing powdery mildew from attacking
the plant so this would be optimal if we
could uh
use through the breeding program breathe
that into a larger number of uh
cultivars so we're really excited um
about about the powdery mildew work uh
not both the control the fungicide
control strategies as well as resistance
strategies and i think what it will take
uh to control powdery mildew is going to
be an integrated approach of resistant
cultivars
lots of airflow
like you see here
[Music]
along with
potentially some of the biofungicides
that ali found to be effective so
questions for ellie
no questions wow
do any of these products affect
testing
testing
so the question is do any of the
products affect testing um
so
that's something that
um is an area that we would like to look
more into specifically like
testing for microbials since they are
uh
bio control products so that's not
something we've looked at yet but it's
something that um
would be
in a future thing we want to look at
yeah a lot of growers will stop spraying
uh bacillus products two weeks prior to
harvest because uh you know
if the microbial testing that happens is
just a total number of colony forming
units that you might get back on a
quality report
bacillus will come up as a
colony-forming unit it will grow on the
media
that it's plated on so
as ali said that's one of the things we
want to work with the
you know the folks that are making the
regulations to make sure that everyone
knows exactly what microbials are being
tested for and um if bacillus is being
tested for then when do we actually need
to stop spraying that biological which
is controlling the pathogen to make sure
that you don't get red flagged in the in
the microbial testing uh
the products that we tested do not
increase um heavy metal or anything else
it would just be the microbials
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu